so we are over here if you could hear
that in the background that's a [ __ ]
waterfall we're at redneck Disneyland
also known as the great outdoor shower
here we have behind us a couple of elk
Buffy chattering the ass I'd touch it
but somebody will probably shoot me in
here just [ __ ] crazy look like a
waterfall in here there was this big-ass
tank of these like indigenous I don't
know Vegas fish or California or fish
found in a Nevada I'm not sure but we're
gonna walk over this way and there's a
[ __ ] aquarium in this place oh and by
the way there's also casino there's also
an indigenous moose in California that
you'll find in Venice Beach called the
moose knuckle the moose knuckle
where your pants are so tight your dick
and your ball sack turns it into
something
hello bamboo here at the great outdoor
world we have your final solution in
camouflage gear camouflage underwear
camouflage suits
camouflage for wedding suits camouflage
turbans telephones camouflage anything
having a night out on the town well
turns out your wife doesn't want you to
have fun one way for you to sneak out
gotta make sure you camouflage so you go
ahead and drink moonshine in the force
with your buddies right here so it's
Halloween you want dress like Super
Mario take it to yourself I need me a
good pair of overalls but you don't want
your friends to see you cos you're
afraid you're gonna look like a dumb
foot guess what
camouflage overalls right there it turns
out it's winter all the leaves fell off
now you're thinking to yourself I want
to lay myself on a pile of dead grass
and nobody's seen well guess what we got
yourself a dead grass
ass jacket right here can't even see me
if you wanted watch this as I disappear
into the floor
thinking to yourself you want to be the
King of Pop but at the same time you
want a hunt so nobody's gonna shoot you
ass in the [ __ ] face guess what we
got ourselves a nice redhead head I
noticed this redhead and it's orange
we like to confuse our customer base
here so you guys can think for your own
about what you want from us that's right
King of Pop king of shot
well here at outdoor world we don't give
a [ __ ] about any animals lives if
they're endangered we're gonna [ __ ]
shoot them great walk sharks fish them
out the [ __ ] water
you know those cheetahs lions tigers and
bears - [ __ ] them - gonna kill all those
little sons of [ __ ]
now I know what you're thinking got an
ex-wife that won't leave you alone maybe
your ex-wife found a new boyfriend I
just talking [ __ ] about you and you're
like you know what ain't gonna have it
want to kill him but you don't want him
to see you guess well we got the biggest
selections of rifles with scopes that's
right people knock his head off from a
distance but love for real close
multicultural love this place ain't for
the slant-eyed time we're not selling no
ninja swords and kung-fu stars if you
know what I'm saying excuse me a little
asian girl you love no I'm gonna buy
this baton were you looking for some
smoke bombs of some sort
perhaps a samurai sword oh you tell me
where that's at we don't have it
I didn't know you could buy like these
collapsible you know you see like cops
like you seen some of those kung fu
movies like those Asian tons of movies
I'm firing one of these I want to whoop
somebody's ass out of nowhere because
here the out great outdoor world we
believe in racial yeah I can't believe
it's actually by the path on a Ladakh
she could save up I live I'm like yeah
it's okay
I shouldn't be very violent on the
street I know nothing about guns all I
know is I feel like a man when I shoot
them
probably not like that but para para
today we are here in Africa we are due
to know that whenever white people come
into a country they always seem to dig a
shoe whatever they want for example
there many shells are lions
still killing our Lions here at the
great outdoor world we like to celebrate
death because in death is life now walk
on over here with me my old brother shot
this beautiful creature that was
drinking out of a creek right on wrong
window Mountain own [ __ ] business we
were like you know what shoot that [ __ ]
in the head and bring a ride home
you ever sit at home have your wife give
you even more ship or sitting on your
ass and watching TV all the time
well coupled up with our nice pair of
camouflage pajamas you can go ahead and
melt right into your little recliner
couch and the [ __ ] won't see what
so here we have a tour for the great
outdoor world now what days are we open
us Monday through Sunday you can get
whatever you need fishing these shooting
needs camping needs and just in general
you just want to [ __ ] up mother nature
that's right humph enough well but this
place is pretty dope I didn't come in
here expecting anything at all and it
has like it's literally like a sport
chalet times for gajillion or a big 5
sporting good times 5 million I think
they told us that the the headquarters I
don't know where it's at but is like a
million square feet this one's like a
bajillion square feet itself so if you
guys have sporting games that you guys
want to come in and check out guns
whatever come through them so make sure
y'all stop on by to outdoor world
because guess what we're gonna [ __ ] up